[Music]
first of all congratulations 100
episodes of Robot Chicken I remember
when this show started I mean it all
started with you is what's so funny code
and the whole idea came from me not
wanting to do another chat interview
right and so I decided to what year was
this do you remember it was uh 99 right
around the time that that MacFarlane
clip was on that's right yes yeah 10
years later and that was it I thought oh
I'll make it short the way that so many
of those guys make shorts and the idea
was you had just had a toy come out and
I was supposed to get a toy from Austin
Powers and I thought maybe if those two
toys like saved the world or something
that would eat up three minutes right
yeah and you showed it on our show and I
remember I think it Britney Spears it
was the star of it it was you and me
going to like a celebrity convention
trying to track down Britney Spears and
you had a crush on right and part of
you're a [ __ ]
yeah yeah and this is you know this was
99 okay maybe both are true but the the
the funny thing is it's 1999 Britney
when she's still like Dancing with Pepsi
right and all that right and you sort of
predicted that she was gonna go a little
crazy I don't want to say that we
predicted it but we definitely called
the early news on her having some crazy
all right let's take a look I think we
we unearthed this clip that you showed
in our show way back in the day let's
let's see how it looks now
oh my god no Bryan I love your show with
me okay 50 great you can be my boyfriend
and we can live together hard and you
can take me to Stowe and help me learn
to drive and votans duh okay can that
love you we're like Romeo and Juliet
without all the family I'm totally down
for you Conan can we just make out don't
draw with me killing I kid you so fast
I just wanted to meet you I loved you
now I'll have to divorce you were
getting abortion the funny is I have
done my own voice you know if you didn't
ask me no one no one noticed